>> THANK YOU ALL.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR COMING
AND ANSWERING YOUR NATION'S CALL
IN A TIME OF NEED.
>> OH, YEAH, SURE.
>> NO PROB.
>> OUR SCHEDULES ARE ACTUALLY
SUPER FLEXIBLE.
>> AND WE LOVE WHITE HOUSE.
♪ JASON DERULO ♪
>> ALSO, I WANT TO THANK MY
PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI FOR
HAVING THE VISION TO SET THIS
UP.
>> I SUGGESTED IT AS A JOKE, AND
THEN IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
>> THIS IS TOUGH ON ME BECAUSE
I'M THE LANDLINE OF PRESIDENTS.
THAT'S WHY I NEED YOU.
I UNDERSTAND PUTIN.
I UNDERSTAND WAR.
BUT THERE'S ONE THING I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
THAT'S COMPUTER.
>> HE MEANS TECHNOLOGY BUT HE
SAYS COMPUTER.
>> COMPUTERS ARE ALWAYS VERY
MEAN TO ME.
COMPUTER SAY, DID YOU MEAN
MAGENTA?"
>> THE POINT IS WE NEED FRESH
IDEAS FROM YOU GUYS ABOUT HOW WE
CAN WIN THE INFORMATION WAR ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
YES, YOU.
>> HEY, GUYS.
I'M AN ACTRESS FROM THE CW.
>> GREAT, WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> ACTRESS FROM THE CW.
AND WHILE PUTIN MAY HAVE TANKS
AND BOMBS, THERE'S SOMETHING
EVEN MORE POWERFUL WE CAN ATTACK
HIM WITH.
POEMS.
>> OH, NO, IT'S THAT GIRL.
♪♪
>> DEAR VLADAMIR PUTIN, IF I WAS
YOUR MOTHER, I WOULD LOVE YOU
MORE.
IF I WAS YOUR WIFE, I WOULD HAVE
BEEN SO, SO, SO MAD AT YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DO YOU HAVE ANY ACTUAL USEFUL
SUGGESTIONS?
>> OH, SURE.
HERE ARE FIVE WAYS TO STOP THE
WAR IN UKRAINE.
>> WHAT'S THAT MEAN?
WHAT'S THAT MEAN?
YOU SEE ANYTHING?
>> I THINK SHE'S EXPECTING TECH
TO SHOW UP.
>> OKAY.
HEY, YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR THING?
>> OH, ME?
LET'S JUST SAY I DO RAPS AND
PRANKS.
MAYBE YOU'VE HEARD OF MY SQUAD,
THE BOO-BOO BOYS?
>> I THINK YOU KNOW THE
PRESIDENT HAS NEVER HEARD OF THE
BOO-BOO BOYS.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
THE BOO-BOO BOYS?
DON'T YOU LIVE IN THE YEESH
HOUSE WITH ONE NET KEVIN AND
DUMBASS LARRY?
>> OH-OH, WE GOT A BOO-BOO HEAD!
>> Y'ALL, ONE TIME THEY PRANKED
A WOMAN DOWN FIVE FLIGHTS OF
STAIRS, IT WAS HILARIOUS.
>> YEAH, AND THEN WE DID A RAP
ABOUT THE AMBULANCE THAT CAME.
>> WELL, THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN
AMAZING HOBBY.
>> WE MADE $13 MILLION LAST
YEAR.
>> GOD, I HATE THIS WORLD.
AND DID YOU HAVE A PLAN FOR HOW
TO DEFEAT PUTIN?
>> OH, YEAH, I'M COOKING
SOMETHING UP.
>> IS IT PUSHING HIM DOWN A
FLIGHT OF STAIRS?
>> IT IS.
>> GREAT.
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
♪ JASON DERULO ♪
>> YEAH, YEAH, I KNOW THAT'S
YOUR NAME, BUT WHAT DO YOU DO?
♪ JASON DERULO ♪
>> I'M SKIPPING YOU, YOU'RE
SKIPPED.
♪ JASON DER RULE LA ♪
>> HOW ABOUT YOU, LITTLE GIRL?
GOD, LOOK, YOU'RE INCREDIBLY
CUTE.
>> THANKS.
THANK YOU.
I DO SILLY ANIMAL MAKEUP FOR
KIDS.
>> WELL, THAT'S ADORABLE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN DO TO
WIN THIS WAR?
>> OH, YOU MEAN THE ONE STARTED
BY YOUR SON, HUNTER BIDEN.
WHEN HE AND HIS PALS AT
BURISMA -- WHERE'S THE LAPTOP,
IS IT IN THIS ROOM?
>> OKAY, THANK YOU, SWEETHEART.
WHAT ABOUT THIS RANDOM
MIDDLE-AGED GUY?
>> HELLO.
MY NAME IS CHARLES F. D'AMELIO.
I'M A ROOFER FROM PITTSBURGH.
>> OKAY.
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I SUSPECT MAYBE THAT YOU HAVE
CONFUSED ME FOR CHARLI D'AMELIO,
THE 17-YEAR-OLD GIRL WITH
130 MILLION FOLLOWERS ON TIKTOK.
>> SOUNDS RIGHT, YEAH.
>> SO I TELL YOU WHAT, I'M JUST
GOING TO HEAD OUT.
BUT FIRST, DO Y'ALL HAPPEN TO
HAVE ONE OF THOSE COVID STIMMY
CHECKS AROUND, BY ANY CHANCE?
>> AFRAID NOT.
>> WE DON'T, I'M SO SORRY.
>> ALL RIGHT, GOOD LUCK WITH THE
WORLD WAR.
NOT WHAT YOU CARE WHAT A ROOFER
THINKS ABOUT PUTIN, BUT MAYBE
YOU SHOULD PUT SOMEONE UP ON A
ROOF AND -- BAM BAM BAM.
Y'ALL HAVE A GOOD ONE.
>> GREAT.
IT'S DOWN TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> WHO, ME?
OH, I JUST GO UP BEHIND PEOPLE
ON THE STREET WITH THIS WEIRD
PIPE AND I GO -- OONGYANGYO!
>> WHAT WOULD YOU DO ABOUT
UKRAINE?
>> I WOULD GO UP BEHIND THE
RUSSIAN TANKS AND GO OONGYANGYO.
>> AND HOW DID YOU GET HERE
TODAY?
>> YOU FLEW ME FIRST CLASS FROM
CALIFORNIA, AND ON THE PLANE,I
WENT UP THERE TO THE PILOT AND I
SAID, "OONGYANGYO."
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY BEST PLAN
I'VE HEARD SO FAR.
>> WHOA!
HEY, HEY, SORRY I'M LATE, GUYS.
SECURITY WAS GIVING ME A HARD
TIME.
>> OKAY, THIS IS AWESOME.
WHO THE HECK ARE YOU?
>> I DO A PUNCH OF INSANE TRICKS
USING A TOILET PLUNGER STUCK TO
MY NIPPLES.
I'M ONE OF THE FAMOUS PEOPLE ON
TIKTOK, IT'S LIKE ME AND
REESE WITHERSPOON.
>> OKAY, WELL WE'RE ACTUALLY
ABOUT TO WRAP THIS MEETING UP
BECAUSE IT WAS CLEARLY A BAD
IDEA.
>> HEY, DON'T DO THAT.
♪♪
DON'T JUST TEAR THE PLUNGER OFF
THE NIPPLE LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW, THE IDEA OF ASKING
TIKTOK STARS HOW TO FIGHT RUSSIA
MIGHT SOUND LIKE A JOKE, BUT
REMEMBER, THEY SAID THE SAME
THING ABOUT THE RADIO IN WORLD
WAR II.
NEVER UNDERESTIMATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
YOUNG PEOPLE.
TIKTOK AND SOME CHILDISH
GIMMICKS MAY HAVE MORE POWER AND
INFLUENCE THAN THE "NIGHTLY
NEWS."
>> WOW.
THAT WAS TRULY INSPIRING, YOUNG
MAN.
>> OH, I'M 55.
NOW IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME, I'M
GOING TO GO MOVE THIS PLUNGER TO
MY CROTCH, ATTACH A KNIFE TO THE
END, AND TRY TO SLICE AN APPLE
IN HALF.
GOD BLESS AMERICA!
>> AND LIVE FROM NEW YORK, IT'S
SATURDAY NIGHT!